this is the Mach V1 Ultra the world's
first cordless stick vac with Steam Mop
that they sent over for review and this
thing has literally blown my mind
because it cleans floors like nothing
I've ever seen before from a bunch of
crumbs or debris on the floor to
literally spill ketchup and thick maple
syrup it cleans it all in a breeze and
the craziest thing is that the mop roll
cleans itself as you go and it stays
really wet so I was able to vacuum and
mop my entire floor and it even has a
sophisticated self-cleaning mode that
heat dries to stop any mildew or
bacteria growth on the mop roll this
thing is absolutely insane and it's
honestly a huge innovation in Stick vacs
and mops it's chock full of technology
that I'm going to explain in this video
but here's a quick rundown of everything
it includes the cordless Steam Wave
technology which is a world's first
Innovation that creates 110gb degrees
Celsius steam to sterilize and kill
bacteria and it's got ecoclean ozone to
disinfect your floors and itself jet
stream technology for powerful vacuum
suction while having low noise 82
minutes of battery life which is way
more than I expected an LCD display with
a bunch of controls to switch modes the
Tesla valve mixing Tech which
automatically mixes detergent with water
the jetblade fan Tech to dry your floors
as you mop a dedicated app to monitor it
and of course the self-cleaning system
when you're done with just a push of a
button that is a ton of tech but before
I get into explaining all of it I've got
to mention that my wife has owned a
house cleaning business since 2017 and
whenever I mentioned getting some sort
of powered stick mop she always refused
and said that nothing can beat manual
mopping but as soon as she tried the
mark V1 Ultra she was instantly
impressed and I'm being fully serious
she actually said that this thing could
replace our Dyson vacuum since the mock
V1 Ultra vacuums and mops at the same
time basically saving you twice the time
it takes to First vacuum with a Dyson
and then mop afterwards this thing will
do it all in one go and it does it
incredibly well just look at the dirty
water bin that I emptied after cleaning
my floors that's how you know it's
actually getting rid of dirt and what
truly blew me away was when I test
cleaned a bunch of wet and sticky
materials on the same tank of water
without any self-cleaning done in
between the sticky materials the brush
roll gets cleaned by the water as you go
first I poured out some milk right on
the floor and as you can see it cleaned
it all up and left no milk residue
whatsoever perfectly clean then I
squirted a bunch of ketchup on the floor
which is a mops Nightmare and just like
that with basically just two strokes it
cleaned it all up and left nothing but
clean floors keep in mind that you would
never do this with a regular mop since
you'd have to instantly wash it to make
sure you don't spread ketchup everywhere
but the mock V1 Ultra washes the brush
mop on the Fly then I sprinkled a bunch
of broken cracker crumbs on the floor to
test how well it vacuums after all that
mopping ending up it vacuumed it all up
instantly then I went even crazier and
poured this thick maple syrup on the
floor and once again cleaned up almost
instantly leaving no sticky residue and
finally I emptied the dirty water tank
put it on the charging base and press
the self-cleaning button which basically
allows the cleaning liquid to flow out
automatically to clean the roller brush
if the cleaning switch is turned on then
it uses ozone cleaning to clean itself
then it drains the dirty water and then
finally it turns on the hot air drying
cycle until fully dry that's it the
unboxing experience was great and this
thing looks absolutely amazing it's
built very well it's very stable and
sturdy and the premium design just looks
awesome from every angle you look at it
inside the box it comes with an extra
filter a cleaning brush with a hair
cutter an extra mop roll a few citric
acid packets for auto descaling and a
bottle of hard floor cleaning solution
which you can simply pour into this
little Tesla valve mixing container
which automatically mixes it into the
water as you clean the charging stand
also looks really cool since it's slim
and Compact and it contains vents for
washing and drying the mop roll when
using the self-cleaning mode now as far
as the Instinct user experience it's
awesome because of the built-in LCD
display showing you which mode you're
cycling through and using but I like the
smart mode because it does everything
automatically or or you can choose the
steam mode which will show this red
loading bar on the mop roll section to
show you when the steam is ready to go
and then the steam mode works crazy well
because it heats up to 110 degrees
Celsius so you get 100 pure steam to
kill bacteria with continuous release
that sprays directly onto the ground to
dissolve oil stains and everything else
while protecting from overheating since
the steam stops when you lift up the mop
and this is all super impressive for a
cordless battery pack design stick vac
but the best part is that it actually
has a speaker with dedicated voice
prompts to let you know when it's ready
as well as other notifications like when
you need to empty the dirty tank or fill
up the clean water tank and thanks to
the Eco clean ozone feature alongside
the steam the mock V1 Ultra is the
industry's first to be certified in
sterilization by TUV Rhineland the way
it works is that the built-in ozone
generator activates the tap water
cleaning both the floor and the vacuum
itself including the brush roll and it's
scientifically proven by the TUV and EPA
to be extremely effective at reducing
germs by up to 99 while still being safe
around kids and pets since the ozone
will break down into oxygen within 30
minutes and that's part of the triple
self-cleaning feature with the Tesla
valve mixing Tech which automatically
makes this eco-friendly cleaning
solution and can store it up to 30 days
in the handle which then washes the
roller brush during and after cleaning
and then the ozone removes odors and
germs and then the hot air cycle make
sure the brush is 100 dried for the next
clean now with all that said I love how
it can vacuum and mop at the same time
and the motor is actually really quiet
for how powerful this action is
specifically up to sixteen thousand
eight hundred PA of suction power while
only being 65 decibels loud thanks to
their three layered noise canceling Tech
and probably the most unexpected feature
is the jet blade technology which
basically blows air behind the mop onto
the floors to dry them as you go so
overall I'm actually blown away by how
well this thing mops I cleaned up all of
my floors on my main level and it was
mind-blowing to see the mob roll stay
wet the entire time which is impossible
with a manual mop since you have to keep
washing it over and over again and the
battery life was mind-blowing because
it's way more than enough to clean my
entire floor and once again my wife
really enjoyed using it and was shocked
at how good it was cleaning and mopping
our floors so with that said I'm
extremely happy with the Mac V1 Ultra
and I look forward to using it for years
to come and if you're interested in
checking it out go ahead and use the
link in the description below along with
my coupon code for an extra discount
this has been Vadim with Max Tech thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video